as Star Trek the Next Generation
concluded his final episode in 1994 many
fans were left wanting more so why was
it gone before its time seemed up not
only had the series been a massive hit
but it was more profitable than most TV
shows at the time trekkies clamored for
comic books action figures novels and
video games only you can make the life
or death decisions required of a star
plus so it seems like a strange decision
to just end one of the most popular and
profitable shows on TV all was not lost
however as a New York Times reported of
the series finale in July 1994
franchises were a big deal in Hollywood
and Paramount wasn't about to take his
eye off the prize even after the end of
the series as the adventures of Jean-Luc
Picard wound down Star Trek Deep Space
Nine was launched with Star Trek Voyager
close on the horizon meanwhile the cast
of the original series led by William
Shatner and Leonard Nimoy still hungar
they've been starring in feature films
as recently as 1991. but so they were
aging and the decades-old franchise
needed a constant infusion of New Blood
to keep afloat in 1994 the castle the
next generation was still made up of the
youngest established crew of the
franchise Deep Space Nine was still
finding its feet and Paramount wanted to
start making movies with a familiar cast
at the helm that meant freeing the Next
Generation cast from their television
obligations the feature film Star Trek
generations debuted in 1994. only months
after the end of the series officially
passing the feature film Torch from
Shatner's James Kirk to Patrick Stewart
Jean-Luc Picard the crew of the
Enterprise D would exclusively destroy
their starship in the same movie
ceremoniously ending their connection to
the small screen with the new Enterprise
E they continued to Star in Star Trek
movies until Star Trek Nemesis in 2002
despite occasional cameos throughout the
franchise the cast of The Next
Generation wouldn't truly reunite until
almost 20 years later for the series
Star Trek Picard another more obscure
reason for the cancellation of Next
Generation had to do with way Network
television operated in the pre-streaming
age at the time Paramount was selling
the show directly to local stations an
unusual move that had paid off well
ultimately the strategy couldn't last
forever due to airtime limitations
stations have bought the show were
required to buy rights to reruns and to
air each episode as many as seven times
as a number of episodes grew with each
season stations are purchased next
generation will be filling an increasing
number of their limited slots with old
episodes and there was no such thing as
Netflix for them to offload all that
content without broadcast time
restrictions by then profitability was
on a downward Trend as the series grew
in size stations were less willing to
pay top dollar for new episodes
meanwhile the main cast of a
long-running series traditionally had
regular pay raises built into their
contracts and the next generation was no
exception the cast was getting paid more
as the show itself made less money to
this day Star Trek the Next Generation
remains a high watermark for many Star
Trek fans it's enjoying a healthy Second
Life on streaming and in syndication
where it continued to be appreciated by
those whose dreams boldly go where no
one has gone before and although it
concluded with some unresolved
Bloodlines my name is many would be
resolved in Star Trek Picard and most
fans agreed that the series ended at the
right time
foreign